avec les députés du groupe l'est
républicain
nous défendons des impératifs comme la
nécessité de mieux rémunérer le travail
afin de faire en sorte qu'ils rapportent
plus que les allocations sociales nous
proposerons défiscalisé les heures
supplémentaires afin d'augmenter le
salaire net nous proposerons de faire
baisser vraiment les taxes notamment sur
les carburants et les taxes sur les
taxes comme la tva sur la tpe nous
proposerons la suppression de la hausse
de la csg pour les retraités et monsieur
le ministre arrêtez de dire que nos
solutions coûte cher car vous savez que
nous proposons aux parallèles les
réformes structurelles courageuse que
vous n'avez pas su prendre depuis cinq
ans il y attend d'économie juste à faire
en parallèle par exemple en luttant
davantage contre les fraudes sociales et
fiscales vous avez évité un vrai bilan
de votre quinquennat pendant la campagne
de la présidentielle vous avez leurrer
les français en ne parlant que de
l'amélioration apparente de l'emploi
mais vous avez caché la dette abyssale
et notre déficit commercial si
inquiétant la france n'est pas dans
l'état que vous décrivez les données
économiques sont moins bonnes que ce que
vous annonciez en surestimant la
croissance en minimisant l'inflation la
france a besoin de vraies mesures
claires compréhensibles
loin des mesures technocratiques et
inégalitaire préconisée par mckinsey
nous porterons ces propositions fortes
et justes pour les français durant les
jours à venir dans l'espoir que vous
saurez enfin les entendre mesdames et
messieurs de la majorité allez-vous
désormais nous écouter pour améliorer
les réponses envisagées afin qu'elle
soit plus juste soyez vraiment au
rendez-vous pour vraiment redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux français de nos
territoires notamment des classes
moyennes qui ont besoin de leur voiture
pour vivre et aller travailler
[Applaudissements]